Добрий день! Сьогодні ми продовжуємо
вивчати карбонові кислоти.
Ми сьогодні познайомимося з
вищими карбоновими кислотами.
Ми дізнаємося про особливості
їхньої будови, властивостей.
Ми дізнаємося, що таке мило,
його склад, і як мило діє на бруд.
Перед тим, як перейти
до вивчення нової теми,
давайте з вами перевіримо
домашнє завдання.
На минулому уроці було задано
домашнє завдання - задача.
Отже, у нас є есенція, із
есенції треба добути оцет.
І есенція, і оцет - це розчини.
Есенція містить 30% кислоти, оцет - 9.
Перевіряємо розв’язання
задачі. Що ми маємо?
У нас є есенція і з есенції
треба добути оцет - 500г.
Нам треба дати відповідь на
питання: чи вистачить есенції?
Для того, щоб дати відповідь на
це питання, ми маємо порахувати,
скільки можна отримати
оцту із цієї маси есенції.
Перед тим, як розв’язувати
задачу, давайте пригадаємо,
що таке масова частка речовини
в розчині - це відношення
маси речовини до маси розчину.
Що означає масова частка?
Масова частка - це маса
речовини в 100 г. розчину.
Якщо ми знаємо масову
частку і масу розчину,
ми легко можемо знайти масу речовини.
Для цього треба помножити
масову частку на масу розчину.
Розв’язання.
Маса речовини - це добуток
маси есенції на масову частку.
Для того, щоб із есенції добути
оцет, есенцію розбавляють.
Маса кислоти при цьому не змінюється.
Тому у другому розчині маса
кислоти буде такою самою.
Ми можемо знайти масу оцту, який
можна добути із такої маси есенції.
Маса оцту - це маса етанової
кислоти поділена на масову частку.
Тобто, із есенції масою 250 г.
з масовою часткою кислоти 30%
можна добути оцет масою 833, 3 г.
Нам потрібно добути 500 г.
Тому, відповідь: есенції вистачить.
Тепер переходимо до вивчення нової теми.
Ми вже з вами вивчили, що таке
карбонові кислоти, давайте пригадаємо!
Карбонові кислоти відрізняються
від інших класів органічних сполук
наявністю характеристичної групи СООН.
Вона називається «карбоксильна група».
Карбоксильна група поєднана
з вуглеводневим замісником.
Якщо вуглеводневий замісник
насичений, то загальна формула
одноосновних насичених карбонових кислот
має таку загальну формулу.
Насичений радикал СnH2n+1.
Вищі карбонові кислоти.
До вищих карбонових
кислот належать кислоти,
до складу яких входить 10
і більше атомів Карбону.
Ми з вами в 9 класі знайомимося
з 3-ма представниками
вищих карбонових кислот.
Вищі карбонові кислоти
ще називають «жирні».
Це тому, що раніше їх
добували лише із жирів.
Тому жирні кислоти.
Перший представник, із яким ми
знайомимося - це пальмітинова кислота.
Пальмітинова кислота
- це тривіальна назва.
Тривіальна назва не
відображає склад речовини,
а от систематична
назва відображає склад.
Тобто, скільки атомів карбону
входить до складу кислоти.
Давайте подивимося. 15 атомів
Карбону у вуглеводневому заміснику
і один в карбоксильній
групі. Всього, 16.
«Гексадеканова»: гекса -
6, дека - 10, разом - 16.
Гексадеканова кислота.
Саме систематична назва
відображає склад речовини.
Структурна формула.
Як можна бачити на моделі,
яку зображено на слайді,
до складу кислоти входять 15 атомів
Карбону в вуглеводневому заміснику
і 1 - в карбоксильній групі.
На цій моделі атоми Карбону
позначено кульками чорного кольору,
Оксиген - червоний, Гідроген - білий.
Стеаринова кислота - наступний
представник вищих карбонових кислот.
Її систематична назва «октадеканова»:
окта - 8, дека - 10, разом - 18.
17 у вуглеводневому заміснику і один
в карбоксильній групі. Разом - 18.
Формула. Бачите, вона
подібна до структурної формули
пальмітинової кислоти, але вона
має на два атоми Карбону більше,
у порівнянні з пальмітиновою
кислотою С17Н35.
І пальмітинова, і стеаринова
кислота - це вищі насичені кислоти.
Тому що вуглеводневий замісник
насичений і відповідає формулі СnH2n+1.
Я думаю, кожен з вас
бачив стеаринові свічки.
Горючим матеріалом для
виготовлення свічки є стеарин.
Стеарин - це тригліцерид
стеаринової кислоти - це жир.
Із жирами ми будемо
знайомитися на наступному уроці.
Наступна кислота - олеїнова.
Дуже складна назва систематична,
зараз спробуємо її розібрати.
Зверніть увагу, чим
відрізняється олеїнова кислота
від стеаринової кислоти
за молекулярною формулою.
У вуглеводневому заміснику
на два атоми Гідрогену менше.
Можна припустити, що оцей
замісник - ненасичений.
Давайте подивимося
на формулу і спробуємо
пояснити оцю складну назву.
«Октадец» це означає 8 і 10 -
18, атомів Карбону 18: 17+1=18.
«енова» Н означає
ненасичена, є подвійний зв'язок,
(між якими атомами?) у назві 9
- це означає подвійний зв'язок
між 9 і 10 атомами Карбону
у вуглеводневому заміснику.
Залишки олеїнової
кислоти містяться в олії.
Давайте спробуємо порівняти фізичні
властивості оцих представників
вищих карбонових кислот, про
які ми з вами сьогодні говорили.
Пропоную звернути увагу
на температуру плавлення.
Температури плавлення
пальмітинової і стеаринової кислоти
не дуже відрізняються, а
от температура плавлення
олеїнової кислоти - 16,3.
Думаю, саме за цим фактом
ми можемо говорити про те,
що за кімнатної температури
пальмітинова і стеаринова кислоти -
це тверді речовини, а олеїнова кислота
- це оліїста і безбарвна рідина.
Запах. Вищі карбонові
кислоти не мають запаху.
Зверніть увагу на густину!
Густина вищих карбонових
кислот менша за густину води.
Я нагадаю, густина води -
1000 кг. на кубічний метр.
Вищі карбонові кислоти
у воді не розчиняються.
Хімічні властивості.
Внаслідок реакції взаємодії
стеаринової кислоти і Натрій гідроксиду
утворюється сіль
(Натрій стеарат) і вода.
Сіль слабкої кислоти (Натрій
стеарат) вступає в реакцію
із сильною кислотою,
наприклад, сульфатною,
і відбувається реакція обміну:
Натрій стає замість Гідрогену,
Гідроген - замість Натрію.
Внаслідок цієї реакції
утворюється стеаринова кислота
і Натрій сульфат (кислота слабка).
Що таке мило?
Розглянемо, як мило діє на бруд.
Зараз на слайді зображено
кислотний залишок.
Кислотний залишок містить дві частини:
полярна частина (С-О-О), і
полярну на малюнку зображено,
і неполярна частина.
Неполярна частина - це
вуглеводневий замісник.
На малюнку також зазначено,
де він умовно знаходиться.
Стеарат аніони неполярною
частиною орієнтуються до бруду,
а полярною частиною - до води.
Таким чином, бруд потрапляє в
оточення мила і легко змивається водою.
Розв’яжемо розрахункову
задачу. Читаємо умову.
Маса Натрій пальмітату...
До солі додали розчин Гідроген
хлориду (хлоридну кислоту).
Визначити треба масу
пальмітинової кислоти.
Записуємо рівняння хімічної
реакції взаємодії Натрій пальмітату
і хлоридної кислоти.
Реакція обміну: Натрій стає замість
Гідрогену, Гідроген - замість Натрію.
Утворюється кислота
і сіль (Натрій хлорид).
За умовою задачі є маса солі,
а знайти треба масу кислоти.
Якщо ми знаємо одну з речовин,
які у нас утворюються або реагують,
то можна знайти будь-яку речовину
за рівнянням хімічної реакції.
Для цього давайте спочатку визначимо,
яка кількість солі
дається за умовою задачі.
Для того, щоб порахувати кількість,
треба масу поділити на молярну.
Маса, за умовою задачі, 141 г.
Рахуємо молярну масу цієї речовини.
Молярна маса чисельно дорівнює
відносній молекулярній масі.
Для того, щоб порахувати масу,
треба додати відносні атомні маси
кожного елементу з урахуванням
числа атомів кожного елементу.
Карбон в таблиці хімічних
елементів - 12, атомів - 15.
Отже, за умовою задачі, кількість
солі - 0,5 моль. Пишемо зверху.
За рівнянням хімічної реакції бачимо,
що в реакцію вступає 1 моль речовини.
Нам треба знайти кислоту.
За рівнянням реакції - 1 моль.
Із 1 моль солі можна
добути 1 моль кислоти.
Тому, якщо у нас солі 0,5 моль, то
і кількість кислоти буде така сама.
За рівнянням реакції ми
знайшли кількість кислоти,
а нам, за умовою задачі,
треба знайти масу.
Тепер рахуємо масу.
Для того, щоб порахувати
масу, треба кількість речовини
помножити на молярну
масу цієї ж речовини.
Кількість - 0,5 моль, молярна маса...
Давайте подивимося, ми
вже рахували масу солі,
чим відрізняється молярна маса
кислоти від молярної маси солі.
Замість Натрію є Гідроген,
тому, якщо ми від маси солі
віднімемо 23 і додамо 1
- це буде маса кислоти.
Отже, відповідь: 130 г.
Із солі масою 141 г. можна
отримати кислоту масою 130 г.
Домашнє завдання. Така нескладна задача.
Дякую! На цьому наш урок
закінчено! Всього найкращого!
Всім привіт!
Мене звати Анна Домніч, і саме зараз
час трохи розім’ятися після навчання.
Я думаю, кожен із вас знає, що
спорт - це сила, краса та здоров’я
і це дуже корисно для нашого організму.
Тож, пропоную вам приєднатись
до наших драйвових руханок
і зарядитися позитивом. Розпочинаємо!
Друзі, привіт!
Ну що, ви вже скучили
за нашими руханками?
У нас сьогодні супершалена
гостя - Леся Нікітюк.
Я така щаслива, думаю, сьогодні
буде просто неймовірна руханка.
Тож, долучайтесь і давайте розпочинати!
Раз-два...
В інший бік!
Спочатку.
Двома ручками.
Двома ручками!
Друзі, здається, вже урок
закінчився, і продзвенів дзвоник!
Леся, я думаю, ти щаслива, що
ми так круто станцювали з тобою!
Давай п’ять! Дякую і до
зустрічі! Біжіть на урок.